Hey, Jake. Yup.
30 seconds to make the diagnosis.
Okay, then, uh,
tell me about the patient.
A 41 year old female.
Presents with jaundice and fatigue.
Jaundice and fatigue.
Okay, and their urine color? It's dark.
Dark urine color.
Okay, likely not unconjugated then. Uh,
what about their liver function tests?
Only mildly elevated.
Okay, so likely not a padocellular cause.
What about ALP and GGTF?
Notably elevated.
Those are notably elevated.
Okay, so it's likely an obstructive jaundice.
Uh, down ultrasound, the biodox,
are they dilated?
Non dilated.
They're not dilated.
So that has to be a intrapatic cause.
And is there than, uh,
AMA? Positive.
AMA and limbo?
Yes. Is it primary billion cholangitis? Yes.